Bonjour à tous et à toutes !
Mercredi 13 juin, c'est la finale de ma thèse en 180secondes.
Et pour l'occasion,
on accueille Davina Desplan,
second prix du jury 2017,
pour nous parler d'émulsion.
Ma spécialité à moi, ce sont les crèmes
hydratantes.
Et en ces périodes de chaleur estivale,
une équipe de chercheurs a décidé de congeler ma crème !
Bah les gars ça va pas là,
je ne peux plus la sortir du pot !
L'équipe de chercheurs de Cavaillon et de Paris
souhaite observer le comportement d'émulsions lors de leur congélation.
Petit rappel,
l'émulsion est la dispersion de gouttelettes d'huiles dans de l'eau.
Comme une vinaigrette, une mayonnaise ou une crème hydratante.
Par contre,
ma crème hydratante est bien plus efficace sur la peau.
Faites-moi confiance.
Alors vous me direz :
si on veut comprendre comment se passe la congélation d'une émulsion,
il suffit de la filmer pendant qu'on la refroidit.
Oui, mais le problème est bien plus
compliqué que ça...
Car pour bien voir le phénomène de congélation,
il faut regarder à l'échelle microscopique.
Et à cette échelle tout se
passe très rapidement.
C'est pourquoi les chercheurs ont
utilisé la microscopie confocale,
une technique d'imagerie particulièrement bien adaptée à ce genre d'expérience.
Et regardez les images qu'ils obtiennent.
Wahou !
C'est plutôt canon non ?
Alors non, il ne s'agit pas de flocons de neiges qui tombent sur les toits,
ni d'un fond d'écran Windows.
Mais bel et bien de vraies images
de vraie microscopie
obtenues par de vrais chercheurs
dans un vrai laboratoire
avec euh ... une fausse mayonnaise.
Les chercheurs ont utilisé différents colorants
pour pouvoir bien observer ce
qu'il se passe.
Les petites gouttes d'huile, c'est ce
qu'on voit en bleu clair.
En magenta, c'est l'eau liquide.
Et la zone bleu très foncé voire quasi-noire correspond à la glace.
La caméra est positionnée juste au dessus de ce qu'on appelle
le front de solidification.
Ce ne sont pas les gouttes qui tombent,
mais bien la glace qui se rapproche d'elles.
Et l'image reste centrée sur la limite eau-glace.
C'est la première fois qu'on obtient des images en temps réel de ce processus.
Et voilà ce qu'on observe.
On peut remarquer un léger ralentissement
au niveau du front de solidification.
En réalité,
Lorsque la gouttelette d'huile va entrer en contact avec la glace en formation,
elle va être retenue à l'interface eau-glace
jusqu'à un certain temps
avant d'être engloutie.
Ce temps est appelé le temps d'interaction.
Les chercheurs ont pu montrer que ce temps
dépend directement de la vitesse de
croissance des cristaux de glace.
Lorsque les cristaux de glace se forment encore plus lentement,
les gouttelettes d'huile sont rejetées
par la glace
et commencent à former de petits agrégats.
Et c'est justement ce que l'on souhaite éviter lorsqu'on congèle notre émulsion.
Pour comprendre plus en détail le phénomène,
ils se sont ensuite intéressés à ce qu'il se passe au niveau de la gouttelette
quand elle est en présence de glace.
1 ... 2 ... 3 ... Soleil !
Ici, les chercheurs ont pu mettre en évidence
la formation d'un film liquide représenté en orange autour de la gouttelette.
Ce film contient de l'eau
et des molécules qui permettent de stabiliser l'émulsion.
On les appelle les tensioactifs
car elles réduisent les tensions entre l'eau et l'huile
qui se détestent un petit peu quand même.
Humm ... beaucoup en fait !
Je dirais même que les
tensioactifs sont les Dalaï Lama
qui amènent la paix dans l'émulsion.
Les chercheurs ont donc procédé à un
recensement de ces molécules pacifistes
et se sont rendu compte qu'elles avaient tendance
à s'accumuler au front de solidification.
Selon les chercheurs,
les tensioactifs seraient au nombre de 100 000
réunis aujourd'hui sur le front de solidification.
Alors que la police annonce plutôt
un nombre de 5 000 molécules
présentes entre l'eau et l'huile.
Ce sont donc les relations initiées par
ces molécules pacifistes
qui déterminent l'harmonie et l'organisation finale de l'émulsion congelée.
Les chercheurs ont ainsi pu mettre en évidence
l'importance de ces molécules
dans l'intégration des gouttes d'huiles dans leur nouvel environnement glacé.
On observe que les tensioactifs, en orange,
se concentrent localement autour de la gouttelette
pendant son engloutissement.
Finalement ce qui est plutôt cool dans tout ça,
c'est que les résultats obtenus
avec une émulsion du type eau-huile-tensioactif
peuvent être transposés à d'autres systèmes complexes.
On peut ainsi comprendre plus finement
les interactions qui entrent en jeu dans
la production d'alliages en métallurgie,
mais aussi améliorer la cryoconservation
de cellules
telles que les globules rouges,
les spermatozoïdes,
en préservant mieux leurs fonctionnalités.
Voilà !
Pour observer cela chez vous,
il ne vous reste plus qu'à faire une petite mayonnaise.
Et trouver un microscope confocal...
On vous invite à suivre la finale de
ma thèse en 180 secondes (MT180).
Histoire de se remettre
de toutes ces émulsions... ces émotions !
Et abonnez-vous !